[Musik]
als gäbe es nicht schon genug Krisen in
der Welt kommen nun auch noch aus China
besorgniserregende Nachrichten nein es
geht diesmal nicht um Taiwan die
Unterdrückten uikuren oder die
Zusammenarbeit mit und auch nicht
umlogistik Staus in den Häfen und
Produktionsausfälle durch brutal
durchgesetzte kovic lockdowns heute
wollen wir eine Frage nachgehen die
mindestens ebenso brisant ist jedoch
gemessen an ihrer monumentalen Bedeutung
in unseren Medien ein viel zu geringer
Stellenwert eingeräumt wird und dies
könnte auch fatale Folgen auf politische
und ökonomische strategieentscheidungen
haben da man wieder mal ein gigantisches
Risiko übersieht bis es zu spät ist die
große Preisfrage für die Weltwirtschaft
lautet nämlich Wiener an einer
Finanzkrise steht China und stimmt es
dass das Bankensystem der zweitgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der weltart gut
gefährdet ist wie abhängig sind wir von
China und könnte einen dortigen Crash
auch uns mit in den Abgrund reißen falls
euch die Antworten auf diese Fragen
interessieren dann jetzt lieber gut auf
denn wir werden mal etwas genauer hinter
die finanzfassade des fernöstlichen
Riesenreichs blicken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den letzten vier Jahrzehnten hatte
ich chinesische Wirtschaft einen der
stärksten wachstums- und
Entwicklungsprozesse der Weltgeschichte
durchlaufen während dieser Zeit hat sich
China mit einer night erregenden
jährlichen Wachstumsrate von dem
Schnitzer 10% von einem Land armer
Bauern zu einer industriellen Supermacht
mit großen Unternehmen Hightech und
hypermodernen Metropolen entwickelt nach
Angaben der Weltbank haben auf diesem
Weg mehr als 700 Millionen Menschen die
Armut hinter sich gelassen das ist
zweimal mehr als die gesamte Bevölkerung
der USA wir sprechen also über einen
Prozess der die Weltwirtschaft den
letzten 40 Jahren stark mitgeprägt hat
es besteht kein Zweifel China ist eine
Welt großen ökonomischen Antriebskräfte
auf unserem Planeten diese Rolle könnte
jetzt jedoch gefährdet sein liebe
visualpolitik Community in einem der
letzten Videos haben wir euch bereits
erzählt dass das chinesische Modell vor
einer tiefen Wirtschaftskrise stehen
könnte wir sprachen von der ersten
großen Krise in China seit gut 50 Jahren
dabei haben wir jedoch ein Thema nur am
Rande berührt das mögliche übergreifende
Krise auf das gesamte chinesische
Bankensystem und deswegen wollen wir uns
dieses Thema heute dafür genauer ansehen
zunächst einmal sei gesagt China ist
nicht nur eine riesige sondern auch eine
sehr ungewöhnliche Volkswirtschaft
bereits seit 2008 stagniert das
Produktivitätsniveau so das ist im
Vergleich zu den Hauptkonkurrenten
Europa und den USA wo es währenddessen
stetig wuchs heute sehr niedrig ist um
dennoch die von der Regierung
vorgegebenen Wachstumsziele zu erreichen
muss das Land daher viel investieren was
mit Schulden finanziert wird hinzu kamen
in den letzten zwei Jahren die
wirtschaftlichen Einbußen durch die
kovid 19 Pandemie die wegen Chinas
totalen Krieg gegen das Virus lange
lockdowns für riesige
industriemetropolen mit sich brachte um
es auf eine knappe Formel zu bringen
Pleiten Pech und Planerfüllung um jeden
Preis und da wie gesagt die Renditen aus
den gewaltigen Investitionen eher
niedrig sind hat dies dazu geführt dass
die Verschuldung von Haushalten
Unternehmen und dem Staat zusammen
genommen über das hinausgeht was zum
Beispiel in Europa oder sogar in den
Vereinigten Staaten üblich ist erinnert
ihr euch an diese Grafik das ist genau
das worüber wir hier sprechen
aber das ist sozusagen nur die Basis des
Problems seht euch mal die folgende
Grafik an
ihr seht wie sich in den letzten Monaten
die Ausfallrate chinesischer
hochzinskredite vervielfacht hat das
sind die Schulden mit den höchsten
Risiko dieser Anstieg der notleidenden
Kredite fällt mit der Flaute zusammen in
der die chinesische Wirtschaft gerade
vor sich hin dümpelt im zweiten Quartal
2022 verzeichnet sich China das
schlechteste Wachstum der letzten 30
Jahre wenn man einmal den heftigen
Einbruch aufgrund der Coronavirus
Pandemie beiseite lässt vergesst bitte
auch nicht dass die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit bereits bei fast
20% liegt während der Immobiliensektor
geradezu implodiert und der
demografische Point of no Return bereits
überschritten ist über all das haben wir
bereits im vorletzten China Video
gesprochen doch am meisten Grund zu
akuter säuge gegen wohl die Signale die
momentan vom chinesischen Bankensystem
ausgehen dabei geht es vor allem um die
Auswirkungen die das Klassen der
Immobilienblase auf das ganzes
Finanzsystem des Landes haben könnte
[Musik]
aber beginnen wir doch chronologisch
gesehen am Ausgangspunkt dieser Krise im
April 2022 waren vier Regionalbanken in
der Provinz hineingezwungen über Nacht
Einlagen in Höhe von fast 6 Milliarden
Dollar einzufrieren die offizielle
Begründung der Behörden lautete dass die
Geschäftstätigkeit dieser Banken
ausgesetzt wurde weil sie offenbar
Einlagen aus anderen Provinzen über
Online-Vermittler angenommen hatten das
ist etwas was den chinesischen
Regionalbanken strengstens untersagt ist
aber drei Umstände sorgten dafür dass
Misstrauen und Angst daraufhin im Land
schnell um sich treffen die Tatsache
dass alle Einlagen eingefroren wurden
nicht nur die aus dem Ausland oder
anderen Provinzen da liegt Tatsache dass
die Behörden versuchten die betroffenen
Kunden zu schweigen zu bringen indem sie
ihnen Schlägertrupps auf den Hals heften
und schließlich die Tatsache dass sich
der Restrukturierungsprozess über Monate
hinziehen wird schon irgendwie komisch
war im ganzen Land ging plötzlich eine
bange Frage um hatte etwa die
Immobilienkrise etwas damit zu tun dass
die Banken plötzlich den Betrieb
einstellen mussten die henna-krise
begann sich dann ab dem 12 juli langsam
zu beruhigen heißt die
Finanzaufsichtsbehörden anfingen
partielle Auszahlungen an die
betroffenen Kunden anzuordnen doch die
Zweifel und die Verunsicherung sind
deshalb nicht verschwunden die Büchse
der Pandora war geöffnet worden und
seither steht die Frage im Raum könnt
ihr den Misere auf den Immobilienmarkt
in China eine Finanzkrise auslösen und
das vielleicht nicht nur in China tja
könnte es zu einer weltweiten
Finanzkrise kommen wie 2007 und 2008
schließlich war es in den USA damals ja
auch eine platzende immobilienpreisblase
die am Anfang der globalen Finanzkrise
stand schnallt Euch jetzt lieber gut an
wenn was euch heute in diesem Video
zeigen dazu manchen aus den Socken hauen
wir legen gleich los und zwar nur nach
einem kurzen werbeinweis von unserem
tollen Sponsor surfshark denn surfshark
VPN ist ein wirklich empfehlenswertes
und sicheres VPN welches zum Beispiel
keinerlei Verbindungsarten natürlich
kann ein vircial private VPN eine nicht
vor allem gefahrenschützen denen es
lauern man muss nach wie vor Umsicht
halten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug sich
mehreren Vorteilen darf zum einen
erschwert ist in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im Netz
nachzufolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit dem integrierten clean Web das
alle Cookies Popups und so weiter blockt
weiterer Vorteil eines VPN ist dass ihr
so tun könnt als während ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum Beispiel
auch Websites und Internetdienste
zugreifen in dem Land in den wir gerade
seid nicht verfügbar wären daheim oder
im Urlaub damit schlagt ihr Zensur und
geoblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
andere Streamingdienste die ihre Inhalte
nur in den USA Anbieten von Europa
ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist noch
nicht alles mit nur einem surfshark
Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks und sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt ihr von surfshark auch
noch ein Rabatt von 83% obendrein die
ersten drei Monate gratis dazu den Link
zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch auch schon
greift damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
PayPal Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit helft
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so zum
Beispiel auch auf unserem neuen Kanal
visual economic.de auf dem es um
Wirtschaft geht bereits in einer Woche
geht er an den Start aber schon jetzt
könnte ihn vorab abonnieren den Link
dazu packe ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung und nun schnell nach China
wo die schuldenbombe immer und immer
lauter klickt gelingt es noch
rechtzeitig sie zu entschärfen
der finanzielle Sprengstoff
in China haben wir bereits eine
geplatzte Immobilienblase der Rückgang
der Immobilienpreise und der Konkurs
vieler Bauträger haben bereits heftige
Unsicherheit ausgelöst die
Unternehmenswerte der bauträgerkonzerne
fiel im ersten Halbjahr 2022 und
sagenhafte 87 %. ja man liegen Zuschauer
das ist ein echter Crash und die
Probleme fangen damit erst so richtig an
Mitte Juli droht zum Beispiel eine
Gruppe von Käufern von noch im Bau
befindlichen Wohnimmobilien die sich
weenatom nennt ihre Hypotheken nicht
mehr zu zahlen wenn der Staat nicht
garantiert dass die Bauten auch
fertiggestellt werden in China besitzen
Hauskäufer ihre verrottenden
unvollendeten Häuser damit ihr das
gigantische Ausmaß dieses
Volksaufstandes da steht es handelt sich
nicht nur um eine lokale
Bürgerinitiative sondern um einen
regelrechten Flächenbrand Mitte
September waren nach Angaben von
Bloomberg bereits mehr als 343
Großprojekte über 100 Städten von diesen
zahlungsboykott betroffen Tendenz
steigend um Ausmaß dieses Mega Streiks
deutlich zu machen bereits im Juli waren
Projekte mit einer Wohnfläche von
insgesamt 231 Millionen Quadratmetern
gestoppt worden das sind 4% des gesamten
chinesischen Wohnungsmarkt ist und ich
in China reagiert der gesamte
Immobilienmarkt sehr empfindlich auf
unfertige Wohnungen da 90% der in China
neu gekauften Häuser schon gekauft
werden während sie sich noch im Bau
befinden ja ihr habt euch nicht verhört
90% vorschussquote das ganze Modell der
chinesischen Bauwirtschaft setzt also
einen großen Vertrauensvorschuss der
Käufer voraus der nun jedoch dabei ist
sich komplett in Luft aufzulösen die
Menschen Misstrauen also sowohl den
Bauträgern als auch den Banken den sie
ihr Geld für noch nicht fertiggestellte
Wohnungen anvertrauen sollen böse Zungen
behaupten gerade chinesische
Immobilienmarkt sei aufgrund der
massiven Dominanz der
vorschussfinanzierung nichts als ein
Schneeballsystem welches jedoch gerade
dabei ist aufzufliegen das Regime in
Peking ist mehr daran interessiert die
staatlichen Institutionen und
und vor allem die milliardenschweren
Eigentümer der immobilienkonzerne zu
schützen als die Hausbesitzer und diese
Agenda bestimmt auch die Reaktion der
Regierung auf die Krise über soziale
Medien haben die Käufer daher über 300
streitgruppen gebildet welche den Markt
für Immobilien gerade zu paralysieren
die Deutsche Bank schätzt den Wert der
von boykosten Betroffenen Hypotheken
auch bis zu 300 Milliarden Dollar was
etwa 5 % des gesamten Marktes für
Hypothekenkredite entspricht damit
explodiert jedoch nicht nur das
Schuldenproblem der Bauträger damit wird
auch ganz massiv geglaubwürdigkeit der
Regierung untergraben und das
wohlgemerkt in einem Land wie China in
den die Behörden eine enorm strenge
soziale Kontrolle ausüben ihr seht also
das ist alles andere als Business as
usual es ist möglicherweise der Beginn
einer echten wende es brodelt so stark
wie noch nie in China ist über die
Immobilienblase der Kampf zwischen
Individualismus und Kollektivismus also
voll entbrannt denn das chinesische
politische System ist nicht auf einem
Wahlvolk aus Einzelpersonen aufgebaut
Polit funktionieren und ihren
Unternehmen sie sind die eigentlichen
Wähler der Regierung auf ihre
Willensbildung ist das gesamte
politische System aufgebaut und das
betrifft beileibe nicht nur den
Bausektor
Chinas Bankensystem ist weithin
staatlich die großen Banken befinden
sich allesamt in Staatsbesitz und sind
zugleich ein wichtiges Werkzeug der
staatlichen Wirtschaftspolitik und
Planung die Führung der großen
Staatsbanken besteht dabei
ausschließlich aus Mitgliedern der
Clique um Shisha ping und wenn dieser
ein Ziel für das Wirtschaftswachstum
festlegt muss jeder im Staatssektor
daran arbeiten dieses Ziel zu erreichen
im Falle der Banken bedeutet das dass
sie dann eben mehr oder weniger Kredite
vergeben ganz wie es von oben verfügt
wird jahrelang bereitet dies keine
großen Probleme als ich jedoch die
Wachstumsraten verlangsamten
insbesondere nach der Krise 2008 wurden
die Banken unter Druck gesetzt mehr
Kredite zu günstigen Konditionen und
gegen geringere Sicherheiten anzubieten
die Idee dahinter war je mehr billige
Kredite zur Verfügung stehen desto mehr
Projekte können umgesetzt werden das
steigert wiederum das
Wirtschaftswachstum ermöglicht das
Erreichen der von der Regierung
vorgegebenen Ziele aber wie wir bereits
gesehen haben ist das Problem dabei dass
diese Politik die in China umlaufenden
Schulden vervielfacht und zwar auf ein
Niveau das viel höher ist als das der
westlichen Länder doch damit nicht genug
im Lauf der Jahre hat die Politik viele
der von den Banken finanzierten Projekte
unrentable gemacht guten und fragt euch
vielleicht warum sollte jemand Projekte
mit zweifelhafter Rentabilität überhaupt
bauen wollen tja im Grunde aus denselben
Gründen warum die Banken gezwungen sind
ihr Geld billig zu verleihen sowohl die
lokal oder regionalen Verwaltungen als
auch die Unternehmen aus dem
Staatssektor müssen die von der Führung
vorgegebenen Ziele erfüllen wenn sich
das Wirtschaftswachstum verlangsamt
müssen Sie entsprechend mehr Geld
ausgeben zum Beispiel indem sie
Infrastrukturprojekte bauen die
eigentlich gar nicht mehr benötigt
werden und das Problem dabei ist
eigentlich da wenn ein Projekt nicht
richtig produktiv ist besteht das Risiko
das ist nicht genügend Mittel
erwirtschaftet um die zu Durchführung
des Projekts aufgenommen Schulden
zurückzuzahlen mit anderen Worten im
Laufe der Jahre waren die chinesischen
Banken dazu gezwungen immer riskantere
Kredite zu vergeben um die von der
Regierung gesetzen Ziele zu erreichen
und etwas ganz ähnliches ist eben auch
auf dem Immobilienmarkt passiert vor
allem dank des Verhaltens der Banken
aber Milliarden Jahr Billionen in den
Hypotheken sind sowohl die Nachfrage
nach Immobilien als auch die Preise in
die Höhe geschossen
[Musik]
jahrelang fördert diese Strategie den
Bau von zig Millionen Wohnungen im
ganzen Land und schufen Millionen von
Arbeitsplätzen außerdem wuchs dank der
stetig steigenden Immobilienpreise das
nominelle Vermögen der Privathaushalte
weiter an China wurde also immer reicher
und die Immobilienbranche hatte damit
sehr viel zu tun sie war sozusagen eine
der großen Wirtschaftsmotoren des Landes
aber hinter den Bauträgern standen dabei
immer die Banken das Problem dabei ist
wie immer die Verschuldung allein die
Haushalte und Immobilienentwickler haben
Bankschulden in Höhe von 7,5 Billionen
Euro angehäuft eine Summe zu dennoch
hinzukommt was unternehmen in den
Immobiliensektor investiert haben wir
können deshalb mit Fug und Recht von
mehr als 11 Billionen Dollar sprechen
und vielleicht ist es sogar noch viel
mehr ja das ist ein verdammt riesiger
Haufen Geld richtig richtig viel Zaster
bzw Schulden aber andererseits China ist
ja auch richtig groß messen wir
vielleicht mit den falschen mit zu engen
oder zu altmodischen Maßstäben gut
betrachten das Problem also aus einer
anderen Perspektive schaut euch zum
Beispiel einmal diese Grafik an
hier seht ihr wie sich die Schulden der
Haushalte im Verhältnis zu Einkommen in
nur wenigen Jahren verdreifacht haben
die Verschuldung der Bevölkerung wächst
also munter weiter bisher sind aber
schon mindestens 26 Immobilienentwickler
in Konkurs gegangen und nach Schätzungen
des britischen Beratungsunternehmens
capital economics stehen in China mehr
als 100 Millionen Wohnungen leer na
hätte angesichts dessen nicht jemand von
euch Lust ins reicht der Mitte zu ziehen
der in diesem Fall solltet ihr aber noch
etwas warten denn es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass die Immobilienpreise
noch einige Zeit weiter senken und sich
die Bautätigkeit weiter verlangsamen
wird dies kannst zu einem Anstieg der
Arbeitslosigkeit führen was wiederum die
Krise in China verschärfen und die
Zahlungsausfälle erhöhen kann in der
chinesischen Volkswirtschaft hat sich im
Bausektor über Jahrzehnt ein gewaltiges
Klumpenrisiko gebildet auf den
Immobilienmarkt entfallen zwischen 20
und 30 Prozent des chinesischen
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das ist schon ein
enormer Anteil im Vergleich zu anderen
Volkswirtschaften und China hat ihn
seinem Investition fermentierten
Wirtschaftsmodell zu verdanken dass den
Bau von Gebäuden in den Vordergrund
gestellt hat es hat so blindem Vertrauen
in immer und ewig steigende
Immobilienwerte geführt was in den
letzten zwei Jahrzehnten ja auch gut
funktionierte aber jetzt eben nicht mehr
denn von Wachstum kann überhaupt keine
Rede mehr sein im Gegenteil Preise für
neue Wohnungen in 70 chinesischen
Städten sind im August im Vergleich zu
vorher unerwarte stark um 1,3% gefallen
und in einem solchen Szenario stellt
sich wieder die Frage wer wäre von
dieser Situation am meisten betroffen
erneut die Banken
Immobilie Krise chinesische Banken
müssen mit 350 Milliarden Dollar
Verlusten rechnen fast ein Drittel aller
Immobilienkredite werden laut einer
Analyse der City Group jetzt als Ausfall
gefährdet eingestuft gegenüber einem
knappen viertel Ende letzten Jahres die
Tendenz ist also klar eine Situation die
im Ernstfall auf viele andere Sektoren
übergreifen könnte und da stellt sich
dann die Frage was die chinesische
Führung angesichts eines solchen Risikos
zu tun gedenkt gibt es überhaupt ein
Ausweg aus dieser verzweifelten Lage
aufgepasst
[Musik]
streng nach bedienungsanleitung
das chinesische Bankensystem ist riesig
und wohl zu groß als dass der Staat ist
leicht retten könnte wenn es nötig
werden sollte um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben wo von der sprechen Ende
Juli beliefen sich die Kredite im
chinesischen Banksystem auf mehr als 30
Billionen Dollar das entspricht etwa
175% des chinesischen BIP außerdem
müssen wir bedenken dass die
Staatseinnahmen in China kaum mehr als
ein Fünftel des BIP ausmachen und
obendrein eine wichtige Einnahmequelle
der öffentlichen Hand just der Verkauf
bzw die langfristige Verpachtung von
Grundstücken und Immobilien ist sollte
es also zu einem ersten Schieflage im
Bankensektor kommen könnte jede Art der
Bankenrettung den chinesischen Staat in
eine sehr schwierige Lage bringen
deshalb ist eines klar wie Glasnudeln
Pekings oberste Priorität ist eine
Finanzkrise zu verhindern die Regierung
muss um jeden Preis dafür sorgen dass
die Dinge nicht außer Kontrolle geraten
und dazu muss sie die in enorme Flughöhe
aufgestiegen aber zugleich mit Problemen
und Ballast überladene Finanzbranche
eine maximal sanfte Landung organisieren
und deswegen kommt es so Nachrichten wie
der folgenden
China überrascht mit Zinssenkungen zur
Bekämpfung der Konjunkturabschwächung
die chinesischen zentralplaner wollen
eine Verschärfung der Krise also um
jeden Preis verhindern und setzen
deshalb auf eine expansive Geld- und
Fiskalpolitik und allerlei
regulatorische Änderungen
einerseits senken Sie die Zinssätze und
Pumpen jede Menge neuer Kredite in die
Unternehmen einschließlich der
individuell steckenden
Immobilienentwickler die Idee ist diesen
Sektor zu stabilisieren und es den
Banken zu ermöglichen sich allmählich
von den riskanteren Vermögenswerten zu
trennen gleichzeitig soll Investitionen
in anderen Sektoren befördert werden auf
der fiskalischen Seite hat die Regierung
große Staatsunternehmen dazu
aufgefordert mehr Mitarbeiter
einzustellen außerdem bringt sie einen
umfangreichen infrastrukturplan auf den
Weg um die Verlangsamung in der
Immobilienbranche auszugleichen
China stellt 1,1 Billionen Dollar zur
Unterstützung von
schießinfrastrukturmaßnahmen bereit
wir haben einen neuen Zyklus der
Infrastrukturentwicklung begonnen das
wird die neue Normalität you shangron
China Ökonomen der citig Group und
sollte das nicht ausreichen könnte der
Staat notfalls selbst in Banken einige
der problematischsten Immobilien
abkaufen
china hat 5001 Milliarden Dollar
rettungsmunition für das Chaos der Staat
wird da sozusagen zu Energie
gigantischen Bad Bank und tatsache ist
das China da noch ziemlich viele Pfeile
im Köche hat es verfügt zum Beispiel
über einige der größten kapitalfonds und
Pensionsfonds der Welt das sind Gelder
die im Notfall mobilisiert werden
könnten um Immobilien anzukaufen und so
die Lage zu stabilisieren im Gespräch
sind rund 500 Milliarden Dollar im
September löste Peking bereits Anlagen
in Höhe von 29 Milliarden US-Dollar auf
und gab diese als frische Kredite für
die Fertigstellung unvollendeter
Wohnbauprojekte aus damals soll das
Vertrauen der Streikenden Käufer
zurückgewonnen werden doch Fakt ist die
meisten von ihnen sind an denen im
Voraus finanzierten Wohnungen gar nicht
mehr so sehr interessiert sie haben sie
zumeist nicht dazu erworben um sich den
Traum von den eigenen vier Wänden zu
erfüllen sondern als Spekulationsobjekte
sie hofften sie bei ihrer Fertigstellung
oder nach einigen Jahren mit Gewinn
wieder verkaufen zu können es ist das
gute alte Prinzip der Hoffnung auf einen
noch größeren Idioten zu stoßen der
bereit ist einen noch höheren Preis für
etwas zu bezahlen was im Grunde niemand
braucht oder sich niemand wirklich
langfristig leisten kann da er es nicht
aus eigener Kraft und Arbeit bezahlen
kann ein Schneeballsystem eben das nicht
auf Produktivität und echter
Wertschöpfung beruht sondern vor allem
auf Spekulationen und nun da die Preise
im Fallen begriffen sind würden viele
liebe aus diesem System aussteigen rette
sich vergangen die in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten von den Chinesen
erarbeiteten und angespannten
Kapitalreserven werden also verfeuert um
den Crash eines möglicherweise
unrettbaren Systems hinauszuzögern und
noch ein paar Spekulanten zu befriedigen
daher ist es gut möglich dass all das
nur vorübergehend wirkt wer gesehen habt
geht es um einen Immobiliensektor und
ein Finanzsystem die vor allem
zusammengenommen zu groß sind als das
der Staat diesen Prozess einfach unter
Kontrolle halten könnte
sollte sich die Krise vertiefen könnten
im chinesischen Banksystem Löcher in
Höhe von hunderten von Milliarden Dollar
entstehen die allein schon in der Lage
wären die Regierung von ins Schlingern
zu bringen wie sehen also die bestimmten
Zahlen dazu aus nun allein die
Finanzierungslücke bei denen nicht
fertiggestellten Wohnungen beträgt rund
112 Milliarden US-Dollar sodass die 500
Milliarden Bazooka der Regierung
durchaus reichen könnte um sie zu
stopfen aber auch damit wäre das System
ja keineswegs reformiert im Gegenteil
seine langjährigen Ersparnisse braucht
China eigentlich dafür um durch
sinnvolle Zukunftsinvestitionen seine
Produktivität zu erhöhen und damit die
Folgen des demografischen Verfalls
aufzufangen nun werden diese Mittel
jedoch dafür benutzt um die Spekulanten
eines gigantischen Schneeballsystems zu
belohnen so dass dieses munter weiter
befeuert wird ein System welches für die
Allgemeinheit nur unrentable
Immobilienprojekte hervorbringt die
Produktivität also weiter senkt es ist
also wie wir bereits im vorherigen Video
zur kritischen chinesischen
Wirtschaftslage erwähnt haben überhaupt
nicht klar ob die altbewährten Formeln
und Schemata diesmal funktionieren
werden denn China hat bereits zu viele
Schulden und zu viel Infrastruktur als
das geldpolitische und fiskalische
Anreize richtig
könnten gegenüber der zu Anfang dieses
Videos erwähnte Gesamtverschuldung ist
nämlich auch die 500 Milliarden Bazooka
einen Tropfen auf den heißen Stein mit
anderen Worten selbst wenn die
Hypothekenkrise unter Kontrolle gebracht
werden wird handelt es sich nur um die
erste Phase einer neuen großen und
langfristigen china-krise dass das
Wirtschaftswachstum in diesem Jahr um ca
4% zurückgeht ist jetzt schon so gut wie
ausgemachte Sache ähnlich markante
Einbrüche beim Wachstum gab es im
Bereich der Mitte schon in der
Weltfinanzkrise 2008 und dann wieder in
der Krise 2020 sollte jetzt aber auch
noch das Bankensystem sos-funken und
Rettung brauchen könnte die bereits
dritte chinesische Krise in diesem
Jahrhundert noch viel heftiger werden
als die vorherigen beiden und da China
ökonomisch eben kein regionaler Player
mehr ist sondern globale Spitzenklasse
würde ein chinesische Finanzkrise die
durch Ukraine Krieg Russland Sanktionen
energiepreisschub inflationsspirale
Nahrungsmittelkrise und und und und die
in diesem Jahr ohnehin schon arg
strapazierte Weltwirtschaft noch
zusätzlich mächtig Beutel es sich also
sich verdammt warm anzuziehen nicht nur
für diesen Winter und zwar sowohl zu
Hause als auch auf dem Finanzmärkten
Chinas Finanzwirtschaft ist eben keine
sichere Bank mehr sondern ein echtes
Risiko das ist größtenteils auch der
Grund warum die kapitalabflüsse aus dem
Land zugenommen haben warum chinesische
Aktien in letzter Zeit stark gefallen
sind ein erheblicher Verlust der
chinesischen Kaufkraft droht und damit
auch der Einbruch der Import Nachfrage
und damit wären wir auch schon in Europa
und seiner Wirtschaftslokomotive
Deutschland die sich in den letzten
Jahren vom Export nach China ähnlich
abhängig gemacht hat wie vom Import
russische Energie Rohstoffe china ist
für Deutschland das zweitwichtigste
Exportland mit über 100 Milliarden
Exportvolumen vor allem in den zwei
deutschen Schlüsselbranchen Automobil
und Maschinenbau haben sich erhebliche
Klumpenrisiken gebildet der Fall
Russland bei dem aufgrund von Profitgier
alle politischen Risiken ausgeblendet
wurden sollte den Lenkern dieser
Konzerne auch in Bezug auf das
totalitäre China eine Lehre sein wenn
die schnellstmöglich Auflösung dieser
Abhängigkeiten nicht zur Priorität wird
könnte ein Platz in der China Blase oder
auch nur das langfristige Entweichen der
Luft daraus zuerst Deutschland und dann
ganz Europa in den Abgrund ziehen aber
nun seid ihr an der Reihe was meint ihr
wird ist der chinesischen Regierung noch
gelingen die Situation zu stabilisieren
und eine den ganz Krise zu vermeiden was
sollte die deutsche Automobil und
Maschinenbauindustrie tun und was kann
man eurer Meinung nach tun um solche
gefährlichen Fehlentwicklungen in
Zukunft auszuschließen und schließlich
haben wir uns das alles nicht eigentlich
nur 2008 nach dem Klassen der
us-hypothekenblase gefragt auf jeden
Fall sind wir auf eure Kommentare zu
diesem Thema schon außerordentlich
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt es bitte ein Like Toys und Freunden
und vergesst nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine kleine Spende
von euch mit der enthält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]